we had this report from Michael Tracy of
these small towns in the midwest where
stores were ransacked windows were
smashed it was by BLM and antifa and
they're like putting up board spray
painting small business please don't
hurt us and things like that
and Tom Cotton wrote sending the troops
the New York Times went to revolt and
Donald Trump said nah nah nah just let
let the country be destroyed by far left
extremists but every Governor has their
National Guards citizen soldiers one
weekend a month they're part of their
National Guard that they control and
they don't do anything well how's that
the federal government's problem I mean
if the federal government can't do
anything about National widespread far
left terrorism then I will just revert
back to the whole National divorce Civil
War conversation because at this point
it's kind of like the federal government
can do one thing it can steal money from
your paycheck and then burn it in
Ukraine